welcome everyone thank you for joining
us at the tissue based research
workflows virtual event our next
presentation for today is how to create
a high quality h e staining protocol
presented by Andrew lazowski
my name is Serena and I will be your
moderator for today's event before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation
to ask a question click on the Q a box
located on the bottom of your screen
type your questions and hit submit this
speaker will answer your questions
following the presentation if you're
having trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the Q a box
to let us know you're experiencing a
problem please join me by welcoming
Andrew for complete biography on our
speaker visit the biography tab on the
left Andrew over to you
good morning good afternoon everyone
thank you very much for joining uh my
name is Andrew lisovsky I'm the
technical application manager at Leica
by assistance and today I would like to
present
um a webinar on how a why quality
matters uh we'll talk about optimizing
um age any efficiency and I'll show you
how to create a high quality protocol
um that will be Bulletproof
so um let's talk about the objective so
as I said um we will talk about h e of
course we'll talk about routine staining
and what really does it mean I will talk
about the routine workflow the steps
involved in the um in that workflow all
the steps leading to h e staining and
that is grossing fixation and
decalsification processing micro Tony
all those steps might and will affect
staining uh we'll talk about the
staining procedures step by step I'll
talk about these different staining
methods and at the end I'll show you
some good examples of the staining uh
protocols and of course we'll close up
with a good one slide summary
so let's talk about routine staining we
keep hearing this term routine staining
or h e so routine staining uh means uh
something that is relatively fast and
relatively inexpensive that is called
routine staining but before I even say
that routine staining we need to say
that uh we why do we need to stain uh in
the first place so we stay in the tissue
because the unstained issue as we all
know
um is transparent uh you can't really
make up any features of the cell solar
features we need to give it a coloration
hence if it's number one method around
the world so I would say I'm 90 of the
slides would go through that method and
of course there is something called
Advanced staining so the advanced
staining and we all know this is
immunohistochemistry or inside to
hybridization those special stains or
special stainings are order when the
routine staining will not enter all the
questions or when the pathologist
um is in doubt and he would ask you to
do something special so today though
we'll only talk and we'll concentrate on
a routine staining
so what you're looking at is a typical
workflow
um through um anywhere in the world um
you go to our Paris France you go to
Moscow Russia or you go to uh
Johannesburg South Africa all those
steps will be there for the workflow the
instruments my various the consumables
might be different but they work for
most likely will be almost identical so
what you're looking at really a lot of
steps uh grossing fixation all those uh
steps will take time and you can see and
read a staining is toward the end of
course so um as you can imagine all the
steps proceeding uh the step might and
eventually will affect the quality of
the staining so
um when we see something unusual during
the staining uh we
um really don't want to diagnose or
troubleshooting the staining itself we
need to go back put that Sherlock Holmes
cap on and thank what could go wrong and
all those steps that would lead on to
this painting step
so let's talk about those steps for a
second so grossing right so the grossing
is the step where you um make that a
specimen or a tissue given to uh or sent
to a histology lab fit a histology
cassette
um very common mistake is where people
are gross or trim the tissue a little
too thick uh we always preach that
tissue needs to comfortably fit a
cassette which is four millimeter deep
so if you do four or five and I press
delete and force the lid to close it I
said you might have problems with the
fixation and later on with processing so
um not optimally fixed tissue will not
give you the ideal coloration or or
staining and of course if the processing
is not correct
um that stain will be affected as well
the fixation itself don'ts are
don't forget that um it's very important
is the tissue to volume ratio we would
say it has to be at 21 20 to 1
um we I've seen ten to one but twenty to
one is with the optimal ratio for this
uh perfect fix station the fixative will
eventually deplete with time uh and will
exhaust its uh function list so you have
to really remember to uh to put that
piece of specimen to a jar that contains
uh the fixative in a 20 to 1 ratio when
using
fixative we need to think about the good
quality effects of the quality uh when I
say quality and known pH so we all uh
want the fixative to be between 6.8 to
7.28 degrees so uh it's you not you
don't have to be chemist to know it's a
pH of neutral
um once the formal in PH uh whether you
make a mistake because you're making it
yourself or you purchase this from some
suspicious Source it's really not a good
quality that pH goes down toward the
acidic so it might reach five or six
once that happen
um you might see something called a
formal impignment within the slide and
you won't see it until you stay in the
tissue actually
um the formal in pigment uh looks quite
interesting quite nice some new people
in the lab might be confused and might
think this is maybe red blood cells
nicely stain or something else that is
just within the tissue but that actually
is the formatting pigment or the acid
formalized hematine that is a due that
is formed due to the low as a low pH of
the formally so again a very important
uh thing to remember about using a good
quality uh fixative and ago and of
course the last bullet point here
duration absolutely uh crucial to
remember
um this uh step is size dependent so
small tissue a little time large tissue
more time a good hist attack will know
how much time is needed but you cannot
really rush it if you rush it on the
fixation will be not complete you will
not be able to probably a microphone or
section such tissue and even even if you
do the coloration of your stain will be
different from the properly fixed tissue
so again uh size and time goes together
you have to remember number about that
so next
um it's the decalcification is this this
is the step that is extra step
um uh employed when you are working with
the tissues that contain ossified cells
right so bony tissue anything bone would
be the calcified
um the classification means really
removing calcium or uh really not
calcium calcium salts hydroxy appetite
are the calcium salt that need to be
removed in order to work with the tissue
like that you need to remove it uh for
the before you process them
um the choice of the assets that does
the decalcification would be dependent
on the size of the tissue so if you're
dealing with uh small uh biopsy uh uh
bone marrow biopsy of course you don't
want to use a strong acid you would use
weak acid the weakest the better uh you
will have to of course control time if
you are working with the large piece of
to it is very hard of course you don't
want to spend days or weeks using weak
assets at that point you will reach out
and use a strong based asset detoxifier
so very important not not all the SSL is
all the same there are strong and weak
acids and you have to be aware which is
uh which is what
um if you overdo it of course if you uh
oops forgot
um I forgot to remove the tissue I went
on a weekend or something like that
you've just simply forgot to remove the
tissue from the jar containing strong
acid you will lose the morphology on the
other side if you all if you undo it of
course inadequate time uh you will not
be able to section because those are
calcium salts will prevent you from uh
creating a perfect section the
processing of course the appropriate
scheduler protocol needs to be used
similarly to the decalsification or
fixation under processing would be
something that make the histologists are
giving a big headache because you will
not be able most likely to even section
such such tissue using optimal reagents
hopefully reagent alcohols reason
alcohols by the way are those alcohols
that's not ethanol I know um ethanol is
very popular for some of us in the
histology Labs region alcohols are the
mixture of isopropanol or methanol and
ethanol and they are relatively safer a
lot much more expensive less expensive
than our ethanol
um used in a gradually increased
concentrations this is the key increased
concentrations we see a lot of people
using um or are using um alcohols on the
tissue processor that should start from
70 and they would jump to a hundred
percent concentration
um while that might work this is not
really optimal you want to really uh
increase the concentration gradually to
remove that water from the tissue very
gently and slowly and only by doing it
in several steps you can be really
successful so gradually increased
concentrations means you start with 7A
you move to let's say 80 85 90 another
90 and then three times to 100 at that
point you do remove all the water
um and uh you can proceed with the
solvents
um and talking about the staining some
people I know use isopropanol so
isopropanol FYI might change the
coloration of hematoxin so while the
hematoxin ideally would be this
beautiful blue right or bluish or
purplish blue uh while um are people
that use isopropyl on my C um well my
hematoxin looks kind of grayish nothing
to do with the staining protocol it
would have to do with the region and the
tissue processor actually things to to
remember is to increase time when you
decide to use any substitutes this a
solvents that are safer than lining so
I'll alignment like products anything
like that would need
um um would would you would have to
increase time and rotate them more often
change them more often because those
bunny substitutes are not as water for
giving as xining so you have to remember
that if you don't do that again
um the um alcohol is not completely
replaced and then you'll have a problem
cutting the tissue and then staining
uh one more thing and this thing that
would lead to the uh sustaining quality
is of course microatomy or suctioning
um a common mistake is people will tell
us hey Andrew we have uh you know
different results uh pathologist is
complaining one sections are darker the
other sections are lighter and what we
would find out is just a simple mistake
and people not even aware of it you have
several technicians um in the lab or
maybe an older microtome
um it's very easy if you think about it
uh the average thickness of the sections
caught in the histology
um around the world is actually about
four four to five if someone makes a
mistake let's say and the lab agrees or
pathologist wants this tissue to be
section four but someone somehow cut it
at five that section will be darker
because 20 while Micron would constitute
for uh for about 20 percent of the
tissue so it's thicker so that 20
percent would absorb much much 20 more
uh dies uh hematoxylite news and so
tissue will look different so our first
thing is to really check
um the settings and the microphones and
of course maybe I'll do the main
preventive maintenance if this is an
older microphone and it's really um and
the microphone is not keeping the preset
uh thickness using the slides um is a
big one
um people would use of course so there
are two types of slides right in general
slides uh what we would call Premium
slides economy slides economy slides are
are not coated with anything premium
slides would be coated with something so
uh premium slides in my mind would be a
slide coated with uh polymers
you can create coded slides in your own
lab using a variety of different
proteins and you if you've been around
on the Block for a while you know people
can use
albumin or a gelatin which is the
hydrolyzed collagen some people with
casein anyway those proteins are okay
they would hold a tissue because that's
the goal right to hold the tissue to
protect the tissue
um uh while the proteins will hold the
tissue they will always create a
background
um background comes from the carboxyl
groups and the proteins and there's
nothing you can do about it you have to
deal with it so
um people sometimes in this too much
background because someone put too much
albumin or gelatin to work into the
water bath they think maybe there is too
much time immersion time and hematoxylin
while this might be the case most likely
this you need to think about the slides
are there the slides that you make
yourself and the left and there's just
too much proteins on the surface and
that those proteins will cause that
background a premium coated slides um as
I mentioned these are polymer coated so
that's nothing to do these are not
proteins anymore so polymer coated
slides would not have carboxyl groups
that would bind and I'm specifically to
hematoxin so if you can if you have this
option uh think about using premium
slides or premium IE uh sealing or um
polymer coated flies that would
um not give you the background on at all
what about additives are protein based
while these products are okay and you
can use them to
um really bind your tissue to the glass
side also they will give you that
background I was just talking about
because
um those additives are protein based so
protein based um uh editors again uh
blue background uh mostly unwanted some
people don't mind but uh really if you
wanted to create a beautiful slide you
want to avoid uh those protein editors
um and of course there are a lot of
things to talk about when you do
affectioning and floating those
beautiful ribbons on the water bath all
about the temperature and people ask us
what is the correct temperature which
section do I need to pick up and we
always say well this smart thing is to
pick this section of course that looks
good to you there is no folding no
bubbles nothing like that and always
always never pick up the sections that
are coming off at the very first two
sections because they tend they tend to
be thicker pick up the good looking
section that will be uh in the middle of
that of the river
so I think it's time now to talk about
the staining procedure itself so what
you're looking at is a simple diagram I
created
um it looks uh bunch of uh different
reagents from left to right and the
staining pathway goes
um so this procedure the staining
procedures as you see are 20 or so steps
depending on the lab could be as long as
little as 15 I've seen up to 28 30 steps
anyway but the idea is the same you have
to run your slides with a variety of
steps the typical
um sustaining protocol would last from
25 to maybe 45 minutes so again
relatively fast comparing of course to
Advanced staining right
um the number and immersion times would
vary depends on who you talk to depends
on the lab
um you remember when you are using where
you um utilizing the automatic stainer
please control the water pressure
um and you can see in gray water
restations these are either if you do it
by hand you just put your water yourself
there's no water pressure whatsoever but
if you're using an automatic stainer the
water pressure control is very important
you I don't want to have the pressure
too high or too low
um and we'll talk about it just in a
second uh and if possible if you do use
that automated stainer please do employ
education for uniform staining
and one more thing that I forgot to
mention toward the right you can see X
for solvent I decided to X as a solvent
cosine X for Designing as still the most
popular solver around the world and a
for alcohol so let's talk about all
those steps uh and uh individually
so the first step for the first couple
of steps would be you can see beautiful
flashing steps these are the uh D Waxing
or deparitanization steps and these are
typically done by xanin or xani
substitutes and those steps are there to
remove the paraffin that is adhered to
the glass
um while you are placing the section uh
straight from the water bath
um if you do not do this correctly if
you try to rush and let's say you do 30
seconds in a 30 seconds you will
experience a um
and staying areas
um of the uh of the of the tissue and
you might wonder
um if uh there's something to do with
the hematoxylene immersion times
um
most likely this is still uh paraffin or
wax attached or covering the uh tissue
uh and it's preventing
um the dice to get uh and create a
chemical reaction so this unstained
portions are due to the paraffin or wax
covering uh the tissue so the times has
to be adequate right so let's say a
minute minimum in my mind maybe two some
people of course would just to make sure
there's no paraffin left they would put
a ferret station so see uh instead of
two a flashing you would see three
flashing uh steps
um next you will see um something called
hydration step so three steps these are
the uh a for alcohol and this is where
you introduce your slides to alcohol
those alcohols start through the
hundreds uh and the last one to the
right the third one most likely will be
95 or maybe a 90.
um that's because the the very first uh
die or very first step of staining this
uh or the slice will be hematoxylene
hematoxin is uh water-based so you don't
want to
um have 100 100 alcohol only you want to
end it uh with a little bit water in it
hence 100 100 and maybe a 90 then a
quick Water Rinse with the right
pressure to remove
um all the alcohol from the slides
before the stain
um so you don't want to of course rush
it again you don't want to uh have the
times uh limited to 30 seconds or maybe
even two stations because now at that
point also not only you introducing your
slides to uh into the uh um aqueous
environment you want to remove uh
signing that were uh uh before that they
were preceding so you want to remove
designing at that point completely and
uh you introducing the slides to the
aqueous environment coming up
so after a brief uh Water Rinse to
remove all the house all the alcohols we
are um at the uh primary staining
primary staining means that's the first
stain or first die in line so uh
hematoxylene
um which is a blue dye uh comes um as we
all know from the tree that grows in uh
Central America
um actually very very old die that
histology people used for at least 150
years ago and actually uh as a side note
I must uh I like always to say that
hematoxin was known to aspects and Mayas
uh in the beginning of the 16th century
and it was actually used as a Dye
um so anyway going back to the real
world hematoxin is stained the nucleus
of the cells so hematoxin is the um is
um negatively charged and would will
sort of positively turn art and with
stain anything that is negatively are
charged within the tissue or with the
cells and what's negatively charged and
nucleic acids DNA RNA and where are they
located they located in the nucleus so
you can say in general hematoxin stain
the nucleus because that's where the
majority of DNA RNA occupies so
um all those beautiful blue dots after
that I'm saying that hematoxin that it's
attached to the a phosphorus groups of
the DNA are most likely within the uh
cell within the nuclei
um
troubleshooting so um a few things
um people will often ask us do I filter
my hematoxin or do I not do I need to I
don't need to do that so the rule of
Assam is you do filter regressive
hematoxylines and you don't need to
filter Progressive hematoxin and people
say okay fine which one is a regressive
the best uh the best representative of
the regressive hematoxylene is Harris
hematoxylene that's the one that would
people uh would have to you uh filter
you filter
uh you filter out actually something
called aluminum ammonium salts these
salts are edits to the solution to the
formulation as a source of aluminum all
the hematoxin is currently most of them
in the world are aluminum base some of
them are iron but most of them aluminum
so that salt is needed for the for the
hematoxylin uh to bind to aluminum
aluminum is needed to be as a mordant to
attach to the DNA or RNA nucleic acids
so you need aluminum aluminum could be
um as supplied as a salt and Harris
hematoxin or regressive hematoxin will
have a lot of it so uh this is normal
occurrence this is expected that those
the excess of the salts will every day
will go to the bottom of the vessel or
whether this is a cubero bottle so you
would have to filter it on the other
hand uh Progressive hematoxin it's like
uh a Gil mayor all the other a hematoxin
you use in the kids used by different
manufacturers they are progressive there
are five times less of the aluminum
ammonium salts so there's nothing
there's no excess of it so nothing
precipitates nothing goes down so
there's no need
to
um to filter anything out another thing
that people think okay what is this golf
Sheen I would uh I left the hematoxin
over the night and there's this gulf
Sheen that forms on the surface of my
Harris this is the
um this is the effect of oxidation of
hematoxin to hematine and that's only
true for Harris or regressive hematoxin
you need to of course remove it people
would use a piece of gold piece of paper
a tissue you have to like quickly skim
it from the top just remove it from the
top takes a little few seconds now with
the progressive hematoxin means you
don't need to do that because what all
the manufacturers are doing the adding
um polyethylene glycol which is
anti-freeze it's all close to the
anti-freeze almost the same formula it
goes to the top because it's lighter
than everything in that formulation and
it protects the hematoxin from being
oxidized so progress hematoxin can
really oxidize or utilize the oxygen
from the air and and so there's no
effect there's no nothing that sits on
the top of the hematoxin if you see
something like that in a progressive
hematoxin that means
um something went wrong with the
manufacturing uh you probably shouldn't
be using the sematoxin unless you do
filter it but in general you shouldn't
be filtered and you shouldn't be getting
rid of the gold Sheen from the uh
Progressive uh stains
okay so the next step uh would be
um of course after quick Water Rinse to
remove the excess of hematoxin this is a
pivotal uh step in my mind a
differentiator people would use either
strong or weak acid and this is where
one of the uh I would say biggest
mistakes would come people too many
people actually non-chemist
um as this is an asset uh they run out
of the acid they would just grab an acid
from the shelf and from the cabinet
um so you have to know if you're using
um regressive acid uh I'm sorry
regressive hematoxin in some meds of
course when you use hair sematoxin
Hiroshima toxins very very powerful
right you filter it you stain it for a
few minutes uh people do five seven
minutes it tends to be very dark right
you need a very strong acid here at that
step differentiation you need to
differentiate the formalining uh I'm
sorry for many what did I say from a
hematoxin of course you need to remove
all the excess of this hematoxin for
that you need always strong acid
um most likely would be Hydrochloric
acids uh about 10 or 14 dissolved in in
water so for regressive uh hematoxylines
you need strong acid now if you're using
Progressive
um hematoxin Progressive stain you don't
uh use strong acid you use the weakest
possible acid you have in the lab most
likely would be malic acid tartaric acid
acetic acid anything very very very weak
because you don't remove
um the excess of hematoxylin you only
removing non-pacific staining from
um
already seen a large proteins that would
not specifically stain also if remember
when I was talking about the slides that
uh people would do uh would call their
own slides with the proteins and those
proteins will give you this background
because they do have those carboxylic
groups that lack hematoxin so at that
step uh if you use such slides you can
use weak acid to clean the background to
cut off the band between carboxylic
group and a hematoxinin so you can
beautifully the slide the types are
usually 30 seconds maximum a minute and
a half you don't need much longer so
weak acid from for the uh Progressive
stay now troubleshooting and you can
imagine people would switch they would
use uh hematoxin in let's say mayor
hematoxylene or Gill or some or
something that is proprietary for Leica
or any other competitors that we have
out there these uh uh hematoxin that are
part of the kid they are progressive
things if you use a strong acid of
course because you made a mistake
hydrochloride based acid or
differentiator uh you will remove most
likely all of the hematoxin or most of
it and the staining will look very pale
very weak people would call you or call
us and say hey there's something wrong
with your hematoxylene and because
obviously people blame hematoxin or
maybe timing there is wrong the protocol
is wrong well we have to put your you
have we have to put your Sherlock Holmes
can on ask investigate ask people and
then once we learn they use wrong acid
everything's clear two acid was too
strong and simply remove all the
hematoxin insane so very important to
know which hematoxin you use which type
of a hematoxin it is in order to use the
right differential
all right so I always mentioned it
briefly so again and this is important
right this is to uh know which hematoxin
in use and once you know which hematoxin
it is then it will uh um that will tell
you which uh acid to use so again to
re-emphasize my my my last two minute
about the uh hematoxylines regressive
hematoxin strong acid once this is
strong a strong acid
um this is uh
uh you don't need much time and you can
see my stopwatch seconds people have
that for one dip three dips five ten
seconds at the moment don't forget it's
a very strong acid strong acid it
removes excess of hematoxylin and it
brings it uh to what it needs to look
like so this is a regressive method now
uh the other type of course it's a
progressive hematoxin and here you use
weak acid there's a lot of different
requests that you can use out there on
the time and you can see I'm here and my
stuff was a little longer it's no no
longer three seconds most likely be
let's say a minute so this is something
very important for you to remember this
is one of the biggest mistakes people
will do they would simply not know uh
simply which type of the hematoxin they
use and they would use or they do but
they still use the wrong acid
all right so we do uh we do uh um have
your hematoxylene we uh use the correct
acid we rinse the acid and we are into
the next step called gluing so bluing uh
steps is simply converting uh beautiful
purple hematoxylene into a beautiful
blue hematoxin and you might say wait a
second didn't you say chemotoxin is blue
well if you'd make an experiment and
stop your staining
um just to see how the um how the tissue
looks how the cell looks
um add the hematoxylin stage or step
um it's actually purple because
hematoxin is purple
um we don't want to have hematoxin
purple we want to have it blue and you
might say what's wrong with purple well
purple would be too close to the second
die which is coming up to the right
either then using gives you different
shades of red sometimes it's kind of
reddish purplish would be dangerously or
could be dangerously too close to purple
so in order to make the the uh make it a
a bigger difference or differentiate
between those two dice we would turn
hematoxin from purplish or purple into
beautiful blue and all you need to do is
a right bluing solution for 60 seconds
uh one of the cheapest reagents on the
market are fairly easy to make it
yourself you can use your tap water
we'll talk about it in a second or any
commercial uh product all you need is a
solution that is uh that has a pH of 8
and why because at that pH and we don't
know how the science works but we know
that at pH of a that conversion from
purple to Blue happens you don't need
much time 30 seconds to 60 seconds
maximum this conversion happens
when we um evaluate sites and we are
asked to help the customer because they
say hey my flights are too pinkies or
nuclei look kind of like almost used and
we all know right away
um they are probably not using the
bluing solution correctly maybe the
bluing solution is not what it needs to
be or maybe simply the pH is not where
it should be and so uh people for that
tab for that step would use ammonia
pollution diluted of course they use
different lithium and magnesium Salt
Solutions and of course people use tap
water
um tap water is good right because tap
water is slightly
um alkaline so it tends to be toward
eight so it's 7.6 maybe 7.8 however uh
tap water might the pH might change
depends on this Village a town imagine a
tap water in Chicago uh one day Chicago
officials will add maybe chlorine to
kill the bacteria and and that pH goes
down to seven or less or if you small if
you live in a small town Village People
officials
um Engineers that develop the site they
need to add something else to the water
solution even if it's temporary that
would affect your staining if your
stainer is connected to the tap water
source and people keep forgetting about
it hey I have a week standing today and
we've seen that more than once we would
send our Engineers our scientists and we
would simply test the pH of water and oh
my God pH is six no wonder this is
acidic water actually and the acidic
water causes what very weak Standing
There is almost a very pale very
purplish staining nothing to do with
your
um with your products that you purchase
from whoever it has to do with the tap
water so what we would say please
um if you can and again bluing solid is
very inexpensive you can purchase it
most likely
um at the 20x concentration so one part
to 19 parts of water very inexpensive do
that instead of relying on the pH of tap
water because that might fluctuate that
might cause problems with the with the
stain
so let's go to the next step which is
Water Rinse and usually I don't have
Water Rinse uh flashing up until now
this is the first one first time that I
see you can see with a flash runs why
would I do that because water rims must
be long enough
to completely
eliminate or remove the blowing water as
I mentioned that already more than once
this is alkaline solution pH of a we
don't want any of that get to the eosin
uh so this
um this step I'm trying to activate my
beautiful Arrow this is just to see the
bluing if you do it for Too Short 20
seconds 30 seconds there's a little bit
of gluing solution we'll get actually uh
via carryover into eosin and the eosin
will look pale so pale ears and people
call us hey I had a look here I have a
few of them that really doesn't work
with that well what can be done they
will look to increase the time that
doesn't work because blowing solution is
still getting into it the alkaline
solution uh
uh changes the pH of using making it
very pale
um are raising the pH of using which is
a bad thing so our flashing uh Water
Rinse is member efficient time a minute
maybe even two minutes if you have time
okay so that's that's an important step
um then um the alcohol that goes in
front of the illusion and side note is
here of course this is assuming this is
an alcoholic eosin we know some part of
the world
um some customers uh prefer aqueous
using then of course you would not have
that step this is to prepare the site uh
to enter the alcoholic environment which
is the elusive right the most of us so
um never mind if you're using aqueous
using you would not have that step
whatsoever so but if you do
um that step should contain
um 80 to 95 alcohol because that's what
eosins are using some average contain 80
to 95 percent of alcohol and so this is
how you want to prepare your slides to
enter this uh step uh with the eosin
um so if for some reason using are you
purchasing using that is let's say 75
alcohol then what you do you try to
match that concentration and that
alcohol step should be
um should contain same amount of alcohol
as using but on average again an average
around the world that using content if
you talk about the alcoholic use and
it's about 90 to 95.
all right so we almost done uh we stay
in our user and we are in Houston
actually
um so few things about the using uh
synthetic dye nothing uh interesting
like hematoxamine that I love to talk
about it I wish I could go back to
hematoxin again and talked about the
tree that grows in Mexico and Yucatan
Peninsula
um he was an unfortunately synthetic dye
created about 100 Years Ago by the
German scientists
um it does produce beautiful three
colors so a well uh formulated and uh
are done using will give you three
different colors right so
um that's very important now the
incident staining mites or troubles uh
with using might come from several
different things right the immersion
times of course the poor eosin or some
suspicious swords that not give you
three colors but only two right
um the bluing solution not being washed
out completely and it's getting into
using changing the pH raising the pH
um using will not last as long as other
solution it uh it exhausts a little
faster maybe unless you really monitor
um the uh the cleaning mess of it the
quality of it so
um pH should be monitor
um check the pH of your starting point
so that your if you're using is let's
say 4.3 make sure that uh it stays at
4.3 as long as possible right
um so carry over the alkaline tap water
will cause that user to uh appease to
rise and at that point you have to
replace
um the EU thing
um
removing um using dehydration so you
dehydrate you remove now the water from
the tissue sections and of course you
have uh two or maybe three alcohol
depends
um how much time do you have uh
those um those that use now you can
really play with that very step and
people don't know that uh very well and
they would say hey
um I'm trying to make this eosin a
little lighter a little darker I have
problems it's very tricky actually using
right because there's so many different
things that can happen to it you can
actually play with that step this very
first alcohol to play with the intensity
of the eosin
um if you um if you use a hundred
percent alcohol
um here you will retain the same
intensity intensity and coloration as
the original erosion now if you went if
you want to differentiate it a little
bit and some people called it step not
dehydration but differentiating
differentiating using you you would use
95 or even 90 percent of alcohol why
use them as a chemical has high Affinity
to water it prefers water over alcohol
so if you imagine if you move the slides
from already stained slides from eosin
to alcohol that contains let's say five
or ten percent of water that eosin will
immediately move from all of the stained
tissues to water making it lighter so
you can really play with the
concentration of alcohol and also with
time so if I put again 100 alcohol here
I will retain the coloration and
intensity eosin as it was now if I use
95 or 90 I can make it lighter so people
can apply with the eu's in uh intensity
um
let's see if I mentioned uh everything
that I wanted yes so let's make uh let's
pause it with the last step which is I
believe
clearing so hearing this is where you
want to remove of course all the
alcohols from the tissue sections
um you would use of course
um a solvent again if you're using
solvent or substitutes like ziony
substitutes the limonene products
anything like that you have to uh
increase the time by about 50 or so and
most likely will be replacing or
rotating them more often as again they
not as water for giving assigning is
um and I already mention it immersion
times you can see only two steps and
many different Labs just to make sure
you remove all the alcohol and maybe a
water in the alcohol that is carried
over from eosin completely removed you
would use three clearing stations
a couple of examples uh this is almost
done folks um this is the staining
regressive uh example of the regressive
protocols here we can see regressive
chemotoxin highlighted in yellow
um if that would be Harris most likely
would be five minutes and this is where
you would use strong differentiator
um and again
um not much time needed for that uh
seconds literally three maybe five ten
seconds few days this is all you need on
the other hand if you want to look at
the progressive hematoxylin uh
Progressive answer protocol
um same thing a progressive hematoxin
would be precise time because you will
not be removing anything so let's say uh
three minutes or two minutes 45 seconds
and then weak differentiator which would
be based on a weak acid so these are
examples of the good spending protocols
you can see step number one and two and
the last two steps I want this too but
if um you're not making one million
slides a day you know and you do have
time I really recommend to extend those
uh first and last steps add another step
to make sure you have this beautiful
staining uh you don't have any wax or
paraffin um left over on the slide and
you clear all the alcohols when you are
done
don't let's summarize it so um I did
what I could last maybe 40 minutes it's
a topic we could we could basically talk
about for a day but very quickly so D
waxing is the power for the removal from
the sections adhere to the red light so
this is resigning resulting substitutes
are brought in hydration is the removal
of that solvent and introducing
introducing uh to the aqueous
environment that's why the hydration
last step would be maybe a 90 or 90
alcohol the uh hematoxamine stains uh
hematoxin positively stain a positively
charged would bind to negative recharge
molecules which are nucleic acid hence
you see those on the right beautiful uh
um nuclei stained blue
um differentiating uh step is
um whether you use asset don't forget
um then you need to know which hematoxin
you're using if it's a regressive you
need a strong acid if you use
Progressive hematoxin you would use very
weak acid the weaker the better gluing
step not much science to it you would
convert purple hematoxin into beautiful
blue and this is done to avoid confusion
or avoid hematoxin being uh are too
close to EOS and in terms of our
coloration
um and or um a side note please do if
you can avoid tap water as this is
unpredictable that tap water can change
one day you don't even know of course
the city will not notify you they do
this and um you will blame of course
um someone that the staining looks or
not what it should be it wasn't staining
um using um
uh negatively charged would bind to a
positively charged uh uh our proteins in
the cytoplasm and a good human would
give you three different colors three
different Hues of red uh and dehydration
you remove the water from the previous
steps to uh
or maybe if you're using alcohol that is
95 to play with the intensity of using
uh and a clearing last step is to remove
um everything and prepare the slides uh
to enter the environment of the mounting
media so
um if you let's say you use any
substitutes
um in your mounting media as your
mounting media that last a few steps
should be of course based on a
um designing substitute this is
designing uh straight xining multimedia
you would use uh zanin uh in your um
automated or manual method so I think uh
we are done
so thank you very much uh for uh joining
and hopefully that was helpful
um and I'll talk to you uh next time
thank you very much
well thank you so much Andrew for that
informative presentation
quick reminder to our audience on how to
submit
questions simply type them into the Q a
box and click the send buttons we will
answer as many questions as we have time
for
if you're ready Andrew
first question is
I was told that there is no need to
filter Progressive in the toxins why
I'm trying to look at the questions
[Music]
okay I'm sorry which question do I enter
I'm sorry can you repeat that please
can you hear me
Serena
um can you repeat the question you were
frozen there for a second
I see a question okay so um we lost
Serena for a second
um
can you hear me
okay um so um I I have uh questions in
the queue so I can address though if I
can see our question might using is very
pale despite increased immersion times
what is causing that so
um there might be two things
um that can cause tail or
um uneven staining on the uh ears and so
first it comes to my mind is the not
enough washers after the bluing uh steps
are bluing step is as we all know pH of
a so it's an alkaline solution if any of
that solution gets into the eosin which
is only two steps away
um no matter what you do you will have
um so uh enough not enough work so maybe
increase the worst uh
uh to block all the materials of the
alkaline solution to use them
um second thing that could happen is
that um your protocol contains the
alcohol that follows using at 90 or 90 a
percent and so that's five or ten
percent of water after using uh pulls
the eosin from already staining a slide
so
um using has a higher Affinity to water
much higher Affinity to order them to
alcohol so the slides could be are
perfectly stained with using however the
next step that five or only ten percent
will do that the eosin is being pulled
away and so our rendering are pale on
uh images or in
on Vision so you have a pale um effect
um number two I see
um I occasionally have slides that have
red droplets outside the tissue what is
causing it so that's fairly easy our red
drop droplets it's called Uh EOS and
leaching that most likely caused by
um water content in your alcohol and uh
xylene last four steps so you have to
change or rotate them more often again
using it being pulled outside under the
cover slip and it looks uh very weird
and strange that's the water that is
being uh in your alcohol or xylene so
the remedy is to change more often and
rotate more often
um what does Progressive staining with
regressive element mean so Progressive
hematoxinins
um could be used in
two different ways you can employ them
um in a progressive stain which means
you uh choose the immersion time to the
point that you like so uh it could be
three minutes and 15 seconds or two
minutes and 12 seconds whatever it is
you follow with the you follow with the
bluing and then you just continue with
your protocol there is no
differentiating step there's no uh
nothing like that now with the
regressive element is the acid is the
differentiator right it will be with a
progressive uh hematoxylines would be a
very weak organic acid the weaker the
better acetic acid malic acid something
like that something very weak so
Progressive uh stain with the regressive
element is the addition of very weak
acid not to remove or hematoxin from
over listing nuclei but to remove that
unknown specific uh staining of the
hematoxin let's say to a mucin to a
large protein so you're basically a
beautifying or making your slides
cleaner better so that's what it means
um I was told that there is no need to
filter Progressive hematoxin in twice of
course uh our Progressive hematoxins do
contain
um as all the hematoxin source of
aluminum most likely and that comes as
salts
um aluminum ammonium salts I believe and
those
um salts are in a lot of amount in uh
regressive hematoxinine of about five
times uh the amount that progressives uh
would contain so while Harris or
regressive needs to be filtered um and
it's normal to be expected occurrence
Progressive hematoxins do not have that
much
uh uh uh forced to precipitate
um I can see one more can these
protocols be used for paraffin sections
as well as for the cryo section yes of
course you can use them uh well Cry of
section stands to you may use any of the
protocol Progressive or aggressive
protocol you want but people usually
would do shortened protocol on those
small stainers so abbreviated times no
need to go for 30 or 40 minutes those
protocols can last as little as 10
minutes a couple of washes here and
there and you're done so um so that's
the last question that I see
um I don't know if I enter anything else
um
Okay Serena um so you hear me now okay
you froze the apologies for a second so
uh yeah thank you for answering all
those questions
um if it's okay to wrap it up at this
time uh again a big thank you to you and
thank you to our audience for joining us
today and for their very interesting
questions we will address any questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during our on-demand uh period
via contact information you provided at
the time of registration this session
webcast will be available on demand
after the event that's all for this
session thank you for joining us and we
hope you enjoyed this presentation bye
for now